IRE ADERINOKUN: Travelling to
Krakow has been really awesome.
I don't think I would ever
have come to Poland in my life,
except for having
an event like this.
It happens pretty
much just once a year.
You also can't really
overstate the value
of doing something like this in
the same room as other people.
So everyone helps each
other, and it's just
really great that way.
JEN PERSON: I think
that it is normal to be
a little nervous before
any sort of big event.
But I'm hoping to take
that and sort of channel
into my excitement about
what I'm talking about.
As a speaker interacting
with attendees,
I get to share a
lot of my knowledge,
and also I get to
learn a lot about what
they're doing with all
of our Google products.
This GDD event, there's
so much going on.
I would say that
my one regret is
that you can't see everything.
I think that I'm really
fortunate that you
can check out a lot of our
events that are recorded.
So I can't wait to check
them out later on YouTube.
HADI HARIRI: I love
the place because it's
such a vibrant
community of developers,
and you get people
from all kinds
of areas, technological areas.
You get Android developers
mixed with Cloud developers
mix with frontend developers.
And it really is a
good mix of everything
that Google is providing
for developers.
SPEAKER: We're really excited
about the possibilities
for developers to build
some truly amazing things.
[MUSIC PLAYING]